WOJTEK KALICINSKI: Choosing
the right tools for your app
development is more
important than ever.
And as the Android
platform matured,
so have our needs as developers.
Making great apps
is so much easier
when you have a rich and
complete dev environment.
And this was the driving
decision behind the creation
of Android Studio.
I an Wojtek Kalicinski,
and I'm going
to show you why you should be
using this powerful new tool.
Android Studio is
Google's official IDE
for Android development.
We've combined a robust code
editor with an entirely new
build system based on Gradle.
Let's talk about
the editor first.
The Getting Started experience
is crucial for every app
developer.
So in Android Studio,
we focus on making
it easy to create new projects,
as well as adding modules
to support Android TV,
Android Wear, Glass, and even
the Google Cloud backend.
All you need this to use
one of the provided wizards,
and the selected
modules will be added
to your project, along with
code templates that let you dive
into coding quickly.
For those of you
coming from Eclipse,
we've included a tool that lets
you import legacy projects.
Not only will it create a new
Gradle build configuration
for your app and fix
your project structure
behind the scenes,
it also identifies
commonly used libraries and
brings them in as dependencies,
eliminating the horrible process
of moving folders manually
and getting your build to work.
If you just want to
check out our samples,
there's now a one-click
solution to import them directly
from Google's
repository on GitHub
into a ready-to-build
and run project.
One of my personal
favorites when
working with Android Studio
is the new Project View.
It offers a flattened
representation of your project
structure, giving quick
access to code, resources,
and build files.
In fact, Android Studio will now
only list each resource once,
regardless of which
configurations
like density or screen size
are included in your project.
You can always expand
the resource node
and check out all its versions.
When it comes to getting
things done and writing code,
Android Studio helps
you to stay productive,
while at the same time
making sure that you write
clean and error-free code.
Apart from the usual
helpers you would
expect from your IDE, like
code completion and access
to documentation, we've added
powerful new code inspections
and refactorings, targeting
performance and compatibility.
You can now easily extract
strings into resources,
or even add right to left
support to all your layouts
with one click.
To make sure you never again
press the wrong resource type
to a method, add one of these
annotations to its parameters.
Many of the framework methods
are annotated as well,
so Android Studio
will show an error
if it encounters, for
example, an RGB value where
a color resource is expected.
Android Studio supports
your development flow,
which includes working with
both Java and XML files.
It's easy to switch between your
classes and relevant resources
by clicking this
icon, or Control
clicking any part of the
resource name in your code.
You even got handy
previews of bitmaps
right there in
the Editor window.
To get a quick look at
what your resource looks
like for different
configurations,
or explore theme attributes
in the Layout Editor,
use the Quick
Documentation View.
You can access it by
pressing Control Q or F1,
depending on your settings.
For editing layouts,
there is the choice
of using the visual
design editor, where
you can drag and drop
views on to the Canvas
and manipulate their properties.
Or if you prefer,
you can seamlessly
switch to editing XML files
directly and see the preview
update in real time.
Android Studio will
alert you whenever
you forget to set the required
attribute on your views,
such as layout width or
height, and can even identify
common performance problems.
If you want to see how
your layouts behave
on different screen sizes, or
if your translated strings fit
correctly in other
locales, you can
switch to multi-preview mode.
This will show your
layout simultaneously,
side-by-side on multiple
device configurations.
You can even look at how your
custom themes and styles behave
across Android versions,
which I have to say
is pretty useful when you're
targeting older devices.
Oh, and by the way,
if you are thinking
of localizing your app, just
use the brand new translation
editor that we've created
to streamline this task.
As always, our Android tools
are being built in the open.
You can follow the progress
and get more information
at tools.android.com.
If you haven't already done
so, download Android Studio
from the Android developer site.
Also, be sure to follow
our Google + page,
and join the Android
Tools community
for updates about new
features and releases.
Tune into our next video in
the Android Studio DevBytes
series, where we'll take
a closer look at the new
build system based on Gradle.